Is This a Picture of Mohamed?
Something woke me up at 5:30 this morning.
Maybe it was my Conscience
Maybe it was God
Take your pick.
I'll go for conscience.
In any case
This week Canada's Government is going to consider
an Anti-Islamophobia Motion M103 in Parliament
Before that happens, I have some things to say.
Moses was a murderer
Christ was a bastard
And Mohamed?
Mohamed was a...
Holy Man whose Every Word and Action was Correct
I ask Muslims worldwide: Can I say anything else?
On the week, Canada's government is going to
discuss anti-Islamophobia motion M103 in parliament.
I ask Muslims worldwide:
Can I say anything else?
I ask Muslims in the West: Can I say anything else?
I ask Muslims in Canada: Can I say anything else?
I ask Iqra Khalid, sponsor of M103 in Canada: Can I say anything else?
Is This a Picture of Mohamed?
Where do I cross the line?
This Is a Picture of Christ
This Is a Picture of Mo
This Is a Picture of Moses
Is This a Picture of Mohamed?
This might be a Picture of Mohamed
Did I cross the line?
When do I become Salman Rushdie?
I'm a Westerner.  I am Salman Rushdie.
Iqra Khalid
Are you Salman Rushdie?
When do I become a Danish Cartoonist?
I'm a Westerner.
I am a Danish cartoonist.
Iqra Khalid
Are you a Danish Cartoonist?
When do I become Charlie Hebdo?
I'm a Westerner.
I can criticize
So that things can improve
So that we're not trapped in the dead past
So that we're not trapped
in the embrace of the corpses of the past.
I am Charlie Hebdo
Iqra Khalid
Are you Charlie Hebdo?
Which side are you on?
Every Westerner is Salman Rushdie.
Every Westerner is a Danish cartoonist.
Every Westerner is Charlie Hebdo.
Who is Iqra Khalid?
When push comes to shove,
as it will this week,
Where is she going to stand?
Muslims of the world,
on the week of anti-Islamophobia motion 103 in Canada...
Muslims of the west,
Muslims of Canada,
on the week of anti-Islamophobia motion 103 in Canada...
Iqra Khalid, of Canada,
who sponsored the motion after the murders in Quebec City
On the Week of Anti-Islamophobia Motion 103 in Canada
Can I say:
This is a picture of the prophet Mohamed?
Because if I can't
It's not Islamophobia.
Is This a picture of Mohamed?